So we have to just realize at this point that
the Washington Post does not like Bernie Sanders
from an editorial perspective.
Yeah.
And they're clearly involved in a Bernie smear
operation, even if not completely deliberate
by sort of default.
This is what they are doing.
So I want to look at the Washington Post coverage
of Bernie, but I also want to look back at
the back and forth about the Washington Post's
coverage of Bernie, which actually maybe tells
us even more.
So the first thing is, does the Washington
Post do a bunch of Anti Bernie coverage?
The answer is yes.
That's okay.
They're allowed to.
Let's look at some of the stories.
This is just the list of stories, uh, from
back in March of 2016 during a two day period,
16 negative stories about Bernie, including
some stories implying Bernie as some kind
of misogynist to Hillary Clinton.
Racializing some headlines about Bernie focusing
on white states calling Bernie partisan.
So this is undeniably a very anti Bernie set
of stories at a very key moment in the 2016
primary and it has continued.
If we look at the recent couple of months,
the Washington Post ran a story about Iowa
doesn't like Bernie anymore.
Bernie looking to Canada for affordable drug
drugs like insulin doesn't really make sense.
The NRA helped elect Bernie and Bernie won't
admit it.
Bernie is running into a quote socialist reality
that is interfering with his ideas.
I mean just persistently hammering away at
Bernie.
So Bernie did the right thing.
He spoke up and he said something and the
Washington Post has responded in a really
silly way, completely straw manning Bernie's
complaint.
Bernie said, the Post writes negative things
about me a lot.
This is demonstrably true.
I mean it's just a fact.
And The Washington Post executive editor,
Martin Barron came back and said, oh, Bernie's
claiming with no evidence that Jeff Bezos
is telling us to write bad things about Bernie.
Jeff Bezos has nothing to do with the day
to day decisions editorially of the Washington
Post.
What does that, what Jeff Bezos, what are
you talking about?
Okay.
The Washington Post is owned by Amazon.
Jeff Bezos runs Amazon.
But Bernie wasn't saying that Jeff Bezos is
calling the Washington Post and saying write
bad things about Bernie Sanders.
So the Washington Post is arguing against
something Bernie never claimed, but there
is still something really important to understand
here in a lot of news outlets that have bias.
You will often hear this argument, no one's
telling me what to write.
Therefore there is no institutional bias here.
You hear this all the time on Fox News, news
reporters, no one tells me, no one upstairs
tells me exactly what to say.
We a me when my producers figure out what
to say.
Uh, I and my producers, um, when you hear
from current or former rt people are t being
Russian state television, rt anchors will
say, I have total freedom here.
No one comes to me and says, you've got to
do this or you've got to say that or defend
Putin or whatever.
That's not how it works.
That's an extremely childish understanding
of how it works.
People are hired because they are being selected
for what it is they are going to do.
Our t anchors are hired not so that they can
be told what to do, but because they wouldn't
need to be told they are selected to fill
a certain role.
Same thing on Fox News and the Washington
Post.
You know, Bernie never claimed Bayzos is telling
people what to write, but the way it works
is that the newsroom is assembled to get people
writing what it is that the Washington Post
wants written.
It could be Bezos or someone else who is making
the general call about what the attitude is
going to be or not, but this is the way it
works.
The reporters writing this stuff at the Washington
Post most likely don't need to be told right
negative stuff about Bernie.
At the end of the day, none of this is surprising.
The Washington Post has done really good investigative
stuff in the Trump era and that's good and
we can praise them for it.
At the same time, when it comes to the dem
primary, the Washington Post is demonstrably
and reliably anti Bernie and their coverage
of democratic primaries.
Okay.
We know that we should be scrutinizing everything
that we take in in terms of media.
This show included, but we can't deny that
without getting into Bayzos is calling the
Washington Post editorially has been consistently
anti Bernie period.
And Bernie's right to call that out.